tu sais ce qu'on aurait pu louper en
restant sur la piste la cascade balej
c'est quoi ça j'ai une culture je sors
j'ai vu quelqu'un
[Musique]
c'est une histoire que les gens
connaissent mais dont ils ne parlent
qu'à bois passe
comme une histoire de fantômes
[Musique]
petit on ne le dérange pas et il ne le
dérange pas
[Musique]
ici
mais kaka manque là où
c'est quoi cet endroit
ils ne reviennent pas
[Musique]
c'est déjà arrivé
comme ce plat descendant de ces gens
vivent encore là haut sur la montagne
oh
[Musique]
il disait qu'il serait les fondateurs
grâce auquel une nouvelle nation serait
créé
m
[Musique]
être l'héritier de ce bouclier c'est
c'est compliqué
[Musique]
le monde va mal
les gens sont perdus
ils ont besoin de quelque chose qui les
protège
un symbole qui les rassemble
alors c'est quoi le plan
[Musique]
t'as pas de plan génial
je serais curieux de savoir ce qui se
passe dans ta tête de cyborg
il vaut mieux pas non voilà ça provoque
dur je vois toute la mécanique
bon un problème technique ya le flou tu
es vraiment lourd
ces pièces défectueuses se surnomme le
ban match
public sera bientôt réorganiser et
deviendra la première puissance qu'a
lactique un période
ça a été un spectacle impressionnant
[Musique]
ce pays
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
et le président obama
promesse tenue
nous avons assumé son cas
sur scène tout fric tabara de ski
sam von whitecaps bois noir
[Musique]
moi je
la raison
à lomé
[Musique]
une bande de costumes
de toi
vous êtes vous déjà senti abandonné
révolte et enragé en public
nos politiciens font de belles promesses
mais toujours dans leur seul et unique
intérêt une vague de violence sans
précédent frappe du quartier défavorisé
depuis que je suis flic je constate
l'impuissance de la justice incapables
de nous protéger des fléaux qui rongent
notre société
la police enquête sur la mort d'une
infusion la plupart se contente
d'espérer des jours meilleurs et moins
grands série 1 2 3 et il s'accroche à ce
qu'ils sont le monsieur x gaydoul vous
insufflez moi je n'ai plus rien je jure
de nettoyer cette ville peu importe le
prime
c'est ça nous ont tué trop d'innocents
[Musique]
moi ce cas-ci pas réussi à lui cinq
personnes sont laissées aucun espersen a
résisté mais cinq fusils à longue portée
où elle suit tactiques de combat
je suis partout
je ne suis nulle part
vous ne m'avez jamais vu
mais vous connaissez mon nom
il vise les plus hautes sphères de la
politique du pays pour la fait désormais
le jeu là comme dans la vie il faut
prévoir les qu il ne s'agit pas de
savoir où on en est mais de savoir où on
en sera dans dix co ou dix ans
une crise cardiaque
comment s'habille lui arrive et va pas
et en meilleure forme qui ne te sont il
ya en fait une chose dont nous devons
discuter
qu'est ce que ça fait ton père a laissé
sa porte ward
et toi seul est ce qu'une seule fille
sur terre connaît vraiment son père
montre moi ton visage
lauren elisabeth moi t'es pas comme lui
on a vite eu meilleur qu'il ne l'a
jamais été
kiel où j'aime bien penser que je suis
un membre de la famille après toutes ces
années
est ce que papa a fait des ennemis dont
je devrais être informé tu sais bien que
c'était pas une personne c'est notre
famille je jetterai son corps dans la
rivière dit que tu avais pas peur la
vérité
il ya des secrets que j'emporterais dans
ma tente
si tu m'apportes que je t'ai demandé
je te promets de tout raconter
est ce que vous vous moquez de moi
est ce que mon père nous cacher un autre
chose à vue d'une avocate un banquier un
politicien a qui te parle est la pire
des trinités ton père n'avait pas le
droit de faire ce qu'il a fait sacrée
femme
tout ça nous prouve rien du tout
moriyasu
mais une fois que je t'aurais tout dit
tu connaîtras la vérité
et là je sais que tu me libère
la vérité doit rester en tête
[Musique]
échappe comment ça se fait que vous
soyez encore en vie
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que tu as fait une
belle chute
à commettre on voit dans le ciel en ce
moment passe au dessus de la terre
environ tous les six ans et ouvre une
morgue mais comme elle s'ouvre
il en sort un visiteur d'une galaxie
lointaine le poète guerrier dans sa
version science fiction
l'homme l'espace corps
vient pour se battre
pour toi ju jitsu et luttons
il n'obtient pas ce qu'il veut il reste
ici et il anéantit tout c'est ça la
règle imposée par brax à ce qu'il
affronte
vous avez tous été choisis
pour être des combattants ju jitsu
mais tant que vous mourrez avec courage
personnes dont on ne sent atteint
[Musique]
il est cinglé comment
mais rien eu l'orgueil a tout à gagner
[Musique]
je sais volet moi aussi
il paraît qu'on voit tous une fois dans
ce métier je crois qu'on n'a jamais vu
ça
[Musique]
tout va bien
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est qu'on ne peut
pas opérer de mentionner
qu'est ce qui se passe mais qu
je veux être sûr de donner du sens à
tout ce que je fais
si vous regardez ça c'est soit que je
suis en train de vous convaincre de
quelque chose qui est assez dur à croire
soir ou quelques jours
n'importe quoi qu'elle revienne mais là
c'est la prochaine dose pourrait tuer
certaines choses sont qu'à pire que tout
qu'est ce qui lui est arrivé il n'en
finit pas
c'est moi qui dois j accepte pas
le sablier n'arrête pas de s'écouler
le temps est une illusion
[Musique]
l'acompte trop de la chance tiens prends
ça c'est quoi pour exaucer tes prières
mortel au québec c'est moi c'était quand
la dernière fois qu'ils avaient des mots
au pardon tu l'a jamais fait on dit à
nos parents qu'on se fait une virée aux
grands lacs et au lieu de ça on passe
tes soeurs espère poli renouvelant par
défi canadienne en strips merde c'est
marrant j'ai klaus ils vont le retrouver
bon je vais aussi la mort année là
tiennent chaque sous la conduite
parfaite
tu fais quoi là j'ai tenu ma carte
estime pourquoi le savoir ce qui se
passe dans mon valent ce que tu trouvé
un lieu qui s'adresse aux gens comme eux
vous allez tirer votre
alors je sais oui s'arrête ses coûts va
où la levade hockey et on fera quoi
quand on y sera vous êtes au courant de
cheveux
allez vas-y appuie ces gars
je crois qu'il commence à gérer
à nos élections qu'elles nous rendent
fiers
merci à toi de quoi pour tout ça
j'ai un truc à vous demander c'est un
peu gênant alors vous foutez pas de ma
gueule évidemment tu choisis il faut
quelqu'un me reste des couilles normes
ex est mort chez obligés d'assister à ça